[Music]
one out of six or so individuals have a
disability but if we look at various
Parliament's where are the people with
disabilities where is their
representation very often persons with
disabilities don't get opportunities to
put themselves forward for these
positions the problem that we're facing
is that government's view persons with
disabilities as a social policy issue I
can give you an example perhaps a
Minister of Transportation or a Minister
of Education will say now that's a
Social Affairs issue that that issue
should belong to that particular
Minister the disability doesn't just
belong in one sector
disability impacts all different areas
of society and a lot of the governments
and people don't realize that but it's
not limited to a social issue which is
how the EU can come in and play a role
by taking disability away from the
social affairs perspective
you can see quite clearly that women
have been put at a disadvantage and the
reason for this are very similar to the
reasons to gender inequality amongst the
non disability community in particular
society it expects less from women and
expects less from women who are disabled
and so they're not expected to achieve
as much as men are or even men with
disabilities now society provided these
women with the same opportunities than
they could achieve more
you